hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember the movie Little Nemo
adventures in Slumberland hub of comic
strip the Opera the game freakin
postcards well then I guess there's no
point of reviewing this
okay let me explain little nemo was a
comic strip in the early 1900s
it was about a boy and his adventures in
his dreams he was creative and ran for
several years but that's not our focus
our focus is on the animated feature
what kind of dream this is an
interesting little film and to be fair
you can't really talk about it unless
you go into a little bit of the film's
history it was supposed to be the big
showcase to America of Japan's great
animation studio TMS who you'd later
recognize from such works as Tiny Toons
Animaniacs and Bevin but in your anime
niche tribute you said it was ek what's
bad geez oh it's not a production in
1982 but was released in 1989 it went
through several directors several
writers and several idea people like
George Lucas Ray Bradbury Brad Bird and
Chris Columbus were all involved at some
point even the world-renowned Hayao
Miyazaki was attached to it once we're
calling the pleasant production as the
worst experience of his professional
career
what street cred does he have writers
thought they were putting words to the
pictures animators thought they were
putting pictures to the words it was a
mess but surprisingly after all this
chaos it still looks like a mess so
let's sleep perchance to puke this is
Little Nemo first of all on this fantasy
of whimsical wonder and highly praised
animation just look at how creatively
they introduce our credits do you know
oh yeah this is it this is our adventure
its introduction look out they might be
going to purple a hobo in Z so after
that we start appropriately enough with
our hero need
I'm really flying
it can't be Jimmy no you haven't
established anything yet so he's flying
all magical and whatnot but then the
dream takes a sudden dark turn
Little Nemo entering the charming
magical world of death you know most
kids failed ease you into the dark stuff
this just fucking throws you in there
yeah let's hear that calming intro music
now
you
now I'm playing power so he wakes up
from the dream and that's it
they never bring it up again it's
nowhere to be mentioned what's the
purpose of that the show that kids had
the ability to dream oh hey here's
another big shocker
Bill Maher might be snobby so Nemo is
now back in the real world you can tell
by him interacting with his mother
father flying squirrel with airplane
goggles wait whoa come on let's go
this is ignorance even though all the
fantasy stuff happens in his dreams
apparently a flying squirrel with a
verbally challenged Gollum voice has so
placed in solid reality he goes to see a
parade welcoming the circus in town that
will no doubt lead to images and seeing
his dreams would you like a ride so if
you haven't guessed yet most of Nemo's
dialogue consists of Wow and hippie and
you pretty much get more interesting
dialogue out of one of those talking
farm animal toys character says so Nemo
wants to see the circus but his father
says he's too busy to take it will you
take me to see it please papa
perhaps tomorrow Nemo have a wonderful
day oh and I guess that's it for dancing
okay well we cut so later that night
when we see him trying to sneak some pie
away pretending to sleepwalk
it's close and I guess that's it for
that team you know this movie flows
about as smoothly as the Grand Canyon
Rapids but after he goes to sleep we
find he starts dreaming again
and this time he's approached by what
should have been interesting characters
do I have the honor of the dressing
Little Nemo uh-huh I am a professor I am
a genius you can call me professor
genius well I find that name obnoxious
and I'm creative I'm going to call you
obnoxiously uncreative
we have been sent here on a mission
liking Morpheus the king of Slumberland
King Morpheus
if you take the blue banner you'll wake
up in your bed believing whatever you
want to do if you take the red pill
you'll end up in slumber machines so the
king wants nemo to be the official
playmate of his daughter Camille but
Nemo has some reservations wait a minute
this princess is a girl you sure you
want to continue with him being the
protagonist movie you still have time to
switch I'd much rather see what the
father's doing at work but we've all
agrees and leaves probably the most
detailed note explaining what's going on
since the suicide markings from it yeah
that'll explain everything
ah they get him on a blimp heading for
Slumberland and this results in the most
expressive and uniquely creative of
verbal responses Wow we you see he could
have just gone for a while
but instead he went for wow-whee Oh
stand back a little bit more one minute
we might get an entire zip piggy dude
out of him how about taking the helm
Nemo oh no no no you don't want to do
that
Little Nemo seems to be piloting and oh
and burst into flames burst into flames
Nemo has killed God knows how many
enchanted creatures this is the worst
tragedy ever oh I'm at a loss for words
ladies and gentlemen what numbnuts
actually put a small child in charge of
a blimp I
I simply cannot tell you don't we are
aware that we've been using the
Hindenburg joke too much but in this
case we simply found it unavoidable you
will not be seeing this joke ever again
oh the humanity oh the whimsical cuddly
humanity so they make it to slumber land
which looks like every other fantasy
world from every fantasy story and they
tried to introduce Nemo to their king oh
no not again
wait here search the garden our king is
in another castle quick find seven
toadstools and place them in seven
different locations we have to cover
this up as bizarrely as possible but
Nemo stumbles across the king who it
appears it's just a big kid at heart a
big stupid totally responsible kid no
Nemo by delightful boy I have invited
you here to become my sole heir me sir
yes you boy literally just picked your
name from a phone book and like the way
it sounded I stand by my decision and as
my heir Prince it is my solemn duty to
give you the golden key but I must warn
you there is one door you must never
open the door with this symbol on it you
must promise and this promise you must
never break I promise sir I promise you
so when does he break the promise
nothing he then introduces Nemo to his
daughter princess Camille wielder of the
ever enchanting on-again-off-again
British accent it's just that no one has
ever accepted a royal invitation in his
underwear this is not my underwear these
are my pajamas but I believe the Royal
invitation was for you alone and not for
your little rat son
hmm he is not a Christian so I am in my
pajamas so don't make me actually care
about something
come with me me I want to show you all
slumber lads so he'll never guess what
happens next
they show him some neat stuff and he
laughs
this whole movie is like watching
someone else's kid at Chucky Cheese
you're happy they're having fun at first
but soon he'd get bored by it and when
you realize you're stuck there for
another hour and a half you begin to
hate that little kid and his birthday in
chucky cheese and the idea of
celebrating birthdays all together I
hope you're happy movie you got me to
hate birthdays finally comes across a
character that's as bored as we are
called flip played by Mickey Rooney the
Care Bears stopped cutting to that he's
considered a mischievous character
because he's committed the terrible
crime of wanting to get the plot goin he
starts some trouble getting some cops
angry at each other which in turn gets
them angry at him
so they fly around cause some trouble
weird stuff happens and guess where this
gives us ok nowhere but like I said
flips job is to do well something even
if it doesn't make a whole lick of sense
and after hiding underground from the
cops they come across the door the king
told him not to open this looks like the
door that the game warned me about what
do you mean he gave me this key it could
be not to open the door with that symbol
let's open it well I guess just a little
peek won't hurt attaboy
you know kid at least Adam had the
excuse that a really hot chick told him
to do it all that persuaded you is a
Teenage Mutant Ninja minstrel show don't
any of your brain cells work in a dream
so because Nemo can handle one thing to
do which was ironically not doing
anything the horrible nightmare king
escapes and plots his evil scheme but
hey that doesn't stop me bow from trying
to make it to the important event where
he's crown prince
oh by the way the one thing I was told
to do I didn't do and now an unspeakable
evil is upon the land crown please it
will be Prince
Nemo's solemn duty to protect
Slumberland from the nightmare King as I
have done the Royal scepter our sole
defense will be passed on to the bridge
dive explained none of this to him but
I'm sure he will be totally cool with it
I hereby crown you Prince Nemo royal
eminence of balls lumber land
so after Nemo fails to explain that he's
fucked up his princely duties even
before he became Prince but King and his
people decide to take part in probably
the most Awkward dancing put to film did
you get to get off
hey guys room Gus we are away
but the nightmare King breaks up the
party and steals the King away
thus everybody wonders who's to blame
and Nemo didn't know
No what are you serious
you just had him wake up from the dream
kind of lazy writing is that oh wait
he's still in the dream uh hold on why
would you tell a story that has a
coherent dream all the way through
except for this one point I mean if the
dream hops around that's fine I
understand but you can't just change the
rules in the middle like that if you're
gonna tell them your story tell a linear
story stick with it don't just jump
around that makes no sense
I mean it's like me in the middle of the
review going ha ha Oh Little Nemo was
just a dream all along oh it wasn't a
dream it was real guess I better go
finish that review
wasn't that pointless
so his room fills up with water and
somehow that leads into the middle of
the ocean there he comes across
professor genius who is surprisingly
forgiving of the fact that he's doomed
everything that he holds dear
because of me it's all my fault
no no dear boy don't blame yourself
blame the writers who didn't give you a
personality so they work their way back
to slumber land where it turns out flip
has a map to nightmare land where
apparently the king is being held so the
princess sends all of her strong's
armies and toughest warriors into
nightmare land
or just a tugboat that works too and
they tried to see if they can locate the
king but they get sucked into a giant
whirlpool underwater and somehow land on
water as it seems they've reached their
destination of nightmare land where
nothing but monsters roam Oh God
let's continue to just point and look at
her to get her free but then come across
a group of goblins who apparently can
master shape-shifting and using 1980s
cartoon sound effects our goblins when
hear the most annoying sound in the
world
but it turns out these are good goblets
who want to help them out on their quest
after of course they sing about it we
got it from some book your escapees from
night vampire interesting trivia here
apparently this sequence was originally
supposed to be used in Jim Henson's
labyrinth but it was quickly dropped
when they suddenly decided it was too
stupid to even think up hey old boy but
going back to what but the nightmare
king sends a bunch of flying creatures
out together yeah tell me a business hey
you guys
Sulaiman my pretties Zuzu really you're
doing the bed thing I did how many times
can you rely on this plot hole to us oh
let me guess
Wow Wow tall well this time the goblins
are here to help it how they get there
it's a dream through P group and they
continue to move for doing
comprehensibility
waitwait if we're honestly going to
start from the exact same point again we
might as well do it the right way so
they come across a sky china and
ironically enough he's asleep so he can
go through it it just seems to have a
little yeast infection so they finally
make it to the lair of the nightmare
king and see if they can find Morpheus
be brave we finally see the nightmare
King at all his glory who actually does
look pretty badass despite the fact that
he's a mix between the monster from Bald
Mountain and a Jackalope give me the
scepter Nemo and I'll let you go I have
to admit though that voice doesn't match
something that size should be
legitimately big and booming this guy
sounds like Tim Kelly doing even
baby-talks
come now for your own sake give me the
scepter so you can hurry home to your
mommy I'm a precious little to Marnie
killer get a young latina but nemo uses
the scepter and finally remembers the
magic words the king said
uh no you have not warranted a silent
moment movie nothing you've done is big
enough that you need to be quiet for a
second to let it sink in so everyone is
set free and the King uses his scepter
to awaken demons your courage destroy
the nightmare King and his evil Kingdom
is gone forever you don't know that
so Slumberland throws a big parade Nemo
smiles with his mouth open we get more
awkward dancing and we get surprised
wake up number 4 ah there are so many
wonderful things waiting for you today
well mom sorry I broke my promise and uh
took the pie oh so that's what this
whole story was about pie wasn't worth
it get ready for what papa
well we decided to go to the circus
today we're going to start yes
while Farkle
so it ends with Nemo going to the circus
aren't you just thrilled aren't you glad
that he's going to the circus I'm not
I'm really not I'd rather see him have
his first wet dream than watch me and
his crap again this was stupid this was
incomprehensible this was terrible let
me enter bitch is nice you ever have
that friend that had that awesome game
system when you were a kid and you spent
all your time at his house playing it
but then when you really think about it
you don't even know the kid's name
that's this movie the animation is
really incredible and allows for some
really creative visuals but everything
else is just so bland and forgettable
the characters are as interesting as
toast the story's a mess and a lot of
times the colors are very stale and dark
now allowing for a lot to look at it had
a lot of behind the scenes problems and
it really shows well it can be creative
and like I said had great animation it
is nevertheless way way way too full I
hate that the films look so long to make
it that there were so many problems
because that just makes the final
product all the more tragic when it
doesn't work and that's all I gotta say
about congratulations nostalgia critic
you have gone this whole entire review
without making one Finding Nemo joke
congratulations
I've got a guy remember so you wait
doesn't this count
what kind of dream do you mean what kind
of dream will be yours to learn where
will you go do you know Little Nemo what
will you do on your mystic midnight